really awesome news we might actually
end up getting static inside the air
over sooner rather than later but
there's a couple who stands to jump
through it's a little complicated so
I'll explain what's up was not expecting
really good news like this this early in
the year they haven't even really
started shooting the shows yet but I'll
go ahead and do a new round of the
giveaway be sure to click that Bell to
enable alerts so you don't miss anything
so what's happening is that the
showrunner was talking about crossover
with the arrow verse in the static shock
character I really he's just called
static so it's a bunch of good news
about what's going on with a black
lightning TV show the characters that it
can do and how that'll crossover with
the other shows when they first drop the
trailer the reason they were saying that
they were going to let him participate
in the big four Knight crossover is
mostly because the show isn't even going
to premiere till 2018 it's going to be a
midseason replacement and on top of that
they produce the TV show in Atlanta
which is on the other side of the
country from Vancouver where they
produce all the other arrow burn shows
it was hard enough for them to cross
Supergirl over when they were shooting
that in Los Angeles during season 1 they
were only able to do all this Supergirl
crossover with the arrow bursts because
they literally shoot right next door to
where they shoot flash and arrow so
you're walking across the street so
that's mainly the reason why black
lightning isn't crossing over right away
but the showrunner was like oh yeah we
definitely want to crossover eventually
that's the first big part of this I'll
talk about how they can crossover
especially given some of the logistical
challenges but there are so many things
the characters have in common so many
story beats that will talk about
crossover stuff in a second the second
big part of this is the static character
he's been all over the animated series
there have been talks about a solo
series for a long time I'll explain
what's up with that too because that got
to bumped a while ago but the showrunner
was saying in success I hope that we can
do this character so he's basically
saying that yeah they could totally do
it but they have to prove that the black
lightning TV show is a success in season
one so depending on how that does it
sort of opens the floodgates on other
big characters that you might want them
to do you may have watched one or more
of the animated series obviously static
shock was the series that started it all
by Dwayne McDuffie may he rest in peace
he was the one that created the care
they did four seasons they did a Batman
Beyond crossover then he went on the
other TV shows like he went on Young
Justice a lot of you probably remember
that I've used the clip of him in black
lightning together they were actually
mentor-mentee for a brief period but
Black Lightning wasn't a big Young
Justice character because it was all
about the kids
so because Black Lightning has two
daughters that develop their own
lightning based powers he's going to be
mentoring them through the course of
season 1 of that show it just makes
sense that he would also mentor the
static character however they want to
surface him on the show he got his
powers because of an accident so there
are a number of ways to introduce him
the black lightning TV show is located
in a suburb is basically like a slum of
Metropolis so if you're just going based
on location it'd be easier for them to
pop up on the Supergirl TV show first
but the fictional city where static is
from Dakota City is actually somewhere
closer to Chicago so it'd be closer to
Central City Missouri
they've been very vague about arrowverse
City locations like for instance
Starling city or star city on arrow
is located in Northern California so
it's way over here when you have super
speed like Barry it just doesn't matter
how far away the cities are that's why
you see him just rush over to arrow
every once in a while to get help from
one of the characters now that we have
Cisco being on another earth doesn't
matter either you could just pop right
over into Cara's living room like they
did during the big crossover but I think
in terms of them doing static on the TV
shows he would pop up there's like a
firestorm type character and if they
really wanted to do them they would
probably introduce them give him a big
arc on the black lightning TV show
crossover with a couple of the other
shows during like some bigger story and
then go off to legends of tomorrow it's
really the best way to do a character
that you don't have room for his own
show and he's too big for one of the
other shows like for instance firestorm
on the flash he's a big character but
he's not quite popular enough to sustain
his own show but he's too big of a
character to make him ride the bench on
the flash and only be in a couple
episodes so you send him to legends of
tomorrow the big team-up show which is
like the island of misfit toys for
characters that aren't popular enough
for their own shows but together they're
able to do something really cool it's
kind of their Suicide Squad style show
that was the whole reason why they
created the Suicide Squad comic they had
a bunch of
as characters that weren't really that
popular so like okay these are a bunch
of bad guys we'll put them in a team up
together will tell bunch of hardcore
stories and it blew up big time for
those of you asking about the
live-action static show that they were
developing a couple years ago so what
happened is back in 2014 it was
announced that Warner Brothers was
releasing or planning to release a
live-action show with Will Smith's son
through their blue ribbon program that's
the service they used to release a lot
of their animated title so you see this
logo sometimes that's what they were
going to use for this static show but
supposedly that was a vaporware and that
was just people trying to hype up a
project they were trying to get going
there were also some rights issues that
were happening between Warner Brothers
in milestone media who originally had
rights to the static character so you
know behind the scenes there was a bit
of drama that prevented them from using
the character in a bigger way even
though he was super popular so now it
sounds like some of that might have been
worked out Warner Brothers is rolling so
hard on dcpip that it seems like a drop
in the bucket for them to figure this
out but the thing is is it static was
not developed inside the DC Universe the
character was created with milestone
media that's why his hometown city is
Dakota City and it wasn't metropolis or
Gotham City or somewhere else
inside the DC Universe later they
brought him into the DC Universe through
all the TV shows but it didn't start out
that way and that's what led to some of
the legal issues it's usually about
money at the end of the day like if you
own a piece of a character in a big
studio wants to include them in the DC
Universe of course you're going to hold
out to you get paid so hopefully all
that dramas behind them will see some
static shock and season - Black
Lightning will see them all crossover
2018 2019 it'll be awesome and they
haven't said anything about Titans
either you have to remember that titans
is another big show where characters can
go crossover on but a lot of these shows
haven't started shooting yet so there's
just a couple questions up in the air
let me know though they use static shock
in the arrowverse where do you want them
to show up how do you want his character
to work do you want him to be closer to
Barry's age do you want to watch him get
his powers or do you want him to just
show up where he already has them and
for those either don't know how his
powers work just think magneto he uses
the Earth's electro
magnetic field he can do all the same
stuff that magneto can do leave all your
requests for DC TV videos in the
comments below I'll announce the
giveaway winner the next time I post a
DC video that'll be sometime this
weekend there was a cool spider-man VR
thing that's going on at theaters now
for spider-man homecoming so I might
post that trailer later it's like a
really cool VR experience that you can
go do for free but while you wait for
everything click here for a brand new
reverse flash and you can click here for
brand new Game of Thrones thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight
you